par delà les montagnes par delà les
plaies de notre grand royaume
j'entends gémir notre peuple quitter la
ville en rangs serrés et ne vous
retournez pas de sombres heures
s'annoncent j'ai l'espoir qu'un héros
destiné à accomplir de grandes choses un
jour se dresse face à la barbarie
ainsi donc c'est toi le valeureux qui a
fléchi le poisson d'art
cela fait de toi un prince et mon futur
beau frère
quel est ton nom
art jaune dans l'ain du mythique
démarrage à une dynastie sans scrupule a
pris le pouvoir
désormais nous les corps havas avons
devant nous l'éternité et dans son ombre
chaque jour un peu plus sage on y court
havas seront bientôt ici laissez les
entrées nous leur parlerons le sang ne
coulera pas
sur un simple coup de têtu perdra tout
incident était sujet tout ce qui t'es le
plus cher non pourtant lorsque tout
semble perdu par arjun part et revient
pour un jour nous venger il l'avait
votre lave et le courage et la bravoure
peuvent faire renaître l'espoir
ce rêve que notre peuple puisse enfin
vivre en paix
nous sommes prêts découvrez la fabuleuse
légende d'un puce devenu guerrier
jour le prince guerrier février 2015